Continuing
[Silence]
in the chapter of repentance of
authored by
Abu Zakaria.
Continuing where we left off in the
narration and discussion that took place
between one of the or the
and
the companion.
He said that he came to ask
regarding the rulings of wiping over the
the footwear.
Now
what is most usually
worn on the foot
in the time of the companions?
Most usually the predominantly worn
thing is referred to as al
or in duality
al
and so because of this a lot of the
narrations
that speak about wiping over one's
footwear
comes in the form of speaking about
wiping over.
This is because it is most predominantly
worn and this is a method of speaking
that is very well known in the Quran in
the Sunnah very constant. So for
instance
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in
It came in the feminine. And I seek
refuge from the
females who blow into knots, meaning
sorcery and witchcraft.
However, it came here in the feminine.
Why? Because this is most prominently
in female circles these things are
done. But it doesn't mean that
a person is seeking refuge only from
female sorcerers or magicians and not
seeking refuge from male. Male and
female is inconsequential here. However,
this is what is predominantly mentioned.
and there are many examples of this
throughout the Quran and Sunnah. So when
we see the evidences regarding wiping
over whatever a person is wearing on his
feet, it often comes in using the words
because that's what's most likely going
to pe be on a person's feet. It's like
for instance, if I were to say wiping
over one's shoes or if I were in a
workplace, a work environment, I say
wiping over your boots, right? I'm
speaking to people in this in this con
construction site and I'm teaching them
about wiping over their footwear. I say
we can wipe over our boots. Why am I
saying boots? Does that mean that we
cannot wipe over our different types
of footwear? We can't wipe over our
socks. We can't wipe over our You can
It's just that most of the people that
I'm speaking to are wearing this type of
footwear. So the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam will use the term.
So this is what is referred to by the
and the as
so the ruling is not necessarily
specific to the material or type of
footwear because the ruling is general.
How do we know that the ruling is
general? Because the reasoning behind it
is general. It's not exclusive for any
type of footwear
aside from another. What is the
reason we are allowed to wipe over our
socks or our footwear? What is the
reason we're not only allowed to but we
are highly encouraged to the point that
it is
mentioned in the books of by the
scholars traditionally it's become
something that is well known as part of
the of the Muslim the beliefs of the
Muslim that they are identified by that
they wipe over their footwear when they
purify themselves for prayer. So we say
why
is
why have we been allowed or permitted or
commanded as Safwan put it
to wipe over our footwear when making
wool because it makes things easy for
us. Right? If a person is wearing a very
thin pair of socks,
very thin pair of socks,
and another person comes and they're
wearing a pair of shoes,
which one could arguably
be in more discomfort or would have to
go out of their way more to make wool.
Both both of them. Or the one with the
socks or the one with the shoes. They're
both in they have to both go out of
their way in order to make woo. They
have to take their shoes off to have to
take their socks off. It could be very
cold out. It could be very hot out. It
could be there's no way to dry your feet
adequately. And now we have fungus and
we have different things that will
will be in a person's feet if they
take their feet out to wash them every
time. So the issue has nothing to do in
the correct opinion with the material
that is used.
Rather the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam wiped over his his
which is a leather substitute. It's a
kind of a leather shoe. He wiped over
his n which are shoes that have a soul
on them.
the companions including his wives wiped
over their their socks even their
cotton socks specifically mentioned. So
the companions understood this to be
something
having little to do with the material
of the
of the of the footwear and having
to do with the importance of the reason
behind this ruling. So why are we
mentioning this? Because because
this narration and a person might think
to himself, why is this narration even
in the chapter of repentance, right? It
has nothing to do with repentance. It
does it has to do with repentance at the
very end of the narration.
So why did Noah mention all this?
Because one of the best aspects of
as opposed to other books of hadith or
compilations of hadith is that he
mentions the entire context
and the entire narration from its
source. He doesn't only take the part
that applies to the chapter. Why is
that? Because of the necessity to it and
the benefit of it. This book is
it is the book that is the gardens of
the believers. It's for every believer.
This knowledge is important not just the
part having to do with repentance. And
so
told him
Wasam.
[Silence]
So he says he used to command us the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
Notice the wording. He didn't say he
used to allow us. He used to allow us to
wipe over our footwear. He used to
command us.
This means that in the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam's time if a
person put his footwear on while he was
in mud it was unheard of to take your
footwear off to wash your feet in mud
unless the time has transpired
or unless the person is in a state of
janab a sexual impurity.
He, the messenger of Allah, used to
command us that if we were travelers
that we should not take off our
orear for three days along with their
nights, except if we are in a state of
jan, sexual impurity,
rather we were to wipe over our footwear
in making wudoo. And here he uses
in making wudoo from
defecating or urinating or sleeping.
And these three are the essence of what
breaks a person's woo. We will mention
it. It's not having to do
specifically with repentance but it is
very important. So we will mention
[Arabic recitation]
the invalidators of wudoo. What are
the things that invalidate a person's
wudoo? There are a number of things that
are mentioned right here that will
invalidate a person's wudoo. Anything
beyond that it is merely preferred
that a person renew his wudoo but it
doesn't necessarily invalidate a
person's wudoo.
Alhamdulillah.